el primer vuelo entre tel aviv y abu
dhabi otro momento histórico después de
la normalización de las relaciones y el
levantamiento del boicot de emiratos
árabes unidos a israel ahora el comercio
y la cooperación pueden comenzar
oficialmente en diversos frentes
esto abre la puerta a lo que solo puedo
llamar comercio sin límites inversiones
en turismo intercambios entre las 12
economías más avanzadas de oriente
medio' y verán como las chispas vuelan
sobre esto ya está sucediendo
el ministerio de finanzas israelí estima
que el comercio bilateral aumentará
aproximadamente a 6.500 millones de
dólares anuales las empresas israelíes y
emiratíes están firmando acuerdos en
materia de investigación médica
agricultura israel dice que ayudará a
mejorar la desalinización del agua y el
cultivo en los desiertos de los emiratos
tecnología y el sector del diamante el
acuerdo con emiratos árabes unidos-
fortalece la seguridad energética de
israel el país se obtiene su petróleo a
través de los oleoductos turcos pero
emiratos trae una ruta alternativa la
normalización facilitará la
transferencia de la tecnología de
defensa de eeuu a emiratos árabes
unidos- los que defienden el acuerdo
dicen que ha ayudado a detener una
peligrosa escalada en el conflicto
israelí-palestino la amenaza israelí de
anexionar el valle del jordán
pero el primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu ha dicho que estos planes solo
están suspendidos temporalmente